- EXCUSE ME, SIR.
DO YOU HAVE A MOMENT
TO SAVE THE CHILDREN?
- I'M SORRY, MAN.
I'M--I'M RUNNING LATE,
AND I JUST DON'T HAVE TIME
TO CHAT RIGHT NOW, SO...
- I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S JUST THAT, EVERY MINUTE,
ANOTHER CHILD
DIES UNNECESSARILY,
A CHILD WHO COULD LIVE
A FRUITFUL LIFE WITH THE HELP
OF JUST ONE SMALL DONATION.
- YEAH, I'M--
I DON'T HAVE THE TIME.
I'M SORRY.
- I UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S JUST, ALL IT TAKES
IS $1 TO SAVE A CHILD.
- ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
FINE, YOU'RE RIGHT.
YUP.
WHO DOESN'T WANT
TO HELP A CHILD?
LET'S SAVE FIVE CHILDREN.
- TOMMY!
ALL RIGHT,
COME ON, COME ON, COME ON.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR, FIVE.
NOT SO FAST.
JUST FIVE.
THANKS A LOT, SIR.
- HELP!
HELP!
[indistinct shouting]
- OH, MY GOD.
I HAVE ANOTHER DOLLAR.
SIR, I HAVE ANOTHER DOLLAR.
[haunting western music]